salvo margaret thatcher listas es la
única primera ministra que ha recibido
un país en la crisis en la que estamos
que no solamente es del costo de vida
sino también de la energía y esto
probablemente se después de la segunda
guerra mundial y es un panorama bien
bien dramático las prioridades por
supuesto y lo que espera la gente es que
anuncie rápidamente cuál será esa hoja
de ruta para ayudar para ayudar el
bolsillo de los británicos cómo resolver
esta crisis que está golpeando a todo el
país la inflación está disparada en un
10 por ciento pero goldman sachs prevé
que podría aumentar hasta un 22% los
precios de la factura de la energía
crecerían porque en octubre habrá otro
incremento hasta uno hasta cuatro mil
dólares por casa y el alivio se espera
que se anuncie no solamente para los
hogares sino también para las industrias
las pequeñas y las grandes listas apro y
ha prometido que presentará esta
estrategia máximo en una semana
como el reino unido se volverá un país
autosuficiente en materia energética
ahora lo que sigue es que el istra se
empiece a anunciar quiénes serán los
integrantes de su gabinete